the kardashian-jenner sisters get a lot
of heat for supposedly having no skills
you don't sing you don't dance you don't
have any any talent kendall Jenner is
also here I'm not exactly sure what she
does but they've built a business empire
with revenue coming not just from their
TV show but also fashion and makeup
lines mobile apps games and endorsements
Kim Kardashian's network is 85 million
who made fifty 2.5 million last year
they have stretched 15 minutes of fame
into nearly a decade and have figured
out how to monetize their every move how
well they understand something about
marketing that most companies don't
advertising surrounds us and as
consequence we've become experts at
tuning it out people are very very good
at recognizing the source and the
persuasive intent that's why the
majority of advertising is really not
successful communications professor
Jennifer looook says that business is
trying to figure out how to make money
online should take a lesson from the
Kardashians most celebrity Twitter feeds
are overtly promotional they're full of
corporate looking ads and tweets that
are clearly written by PR handlers
compare that to Kim Kardashian's feed
she whines about jet lag and asks her
followers whether she should embarrass
her husband it is definitely a dynamic
that comes very close to a perceived
friendship but it's completely one-sided
communication scholars call this
phenomenon Parra social interaction the
researchers who coined the term in the
mid-1950s use it to describe the feeling
of friendship and closeness that people
felt his TV personalities who they'd
never met it don't look like you know
when you're at a concert and somebody is
singing and that person is looking for
the audience they feel like they they're
looking at you and they're singing at
you a reality show like Keeping Up with
the Kardashians is fertile ground for
the beginnings of a parasocial
relationship and commit our sisters
nurture it by speaking to their fans on
social media like their friends
so how prettier those Oh Oh and it
probably doesn't hurt that that includes
a fair amount of nudity so when Kim and
our sisters Hawk products which they do
all the time it doesn't feel like an
advertisement it feels like a
recommendation from a friend a richer
better-looking friend who's getting paid
thousands of dollars to tweet about
swimsuits and teeth whitening the
Kardashians use every digital tool
imaginable to make millions of people
feel like they know them and make
millions of dollars for themselves in
the process and you don't have to
approve of them or even like them to
acknowledge that that's the talent
thanks so much for watching I am
channeling my inner Kim Kardashian to
bring you this videos and credits as a
selfie video and I want to meet you with
what we might call a moment of Zen or
Kardashian's and thanks for watching
nude selfies till I die
[Music]